next is going to be Emily in Tennessee
hi Emily how are you hi Dave I'm doing
well how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I have had my oh crap
moment I am 24 years old single and
their children I make about 35 a year
35,000 a year grows at about 31 and I
had one hundred nine thousand it didn't
load that about 1,300 and credit card
debt so come on baby step two starting
today actually and I am scaling things
way way back but I kind of have two
things here number one I'm just a little
overwhelmed a little freaked out by the
situation that I'm realizing I've gotten
myself into and then also on top of that
I found out yesterday that when my
grandfather passed away about 14 years
ago he left me a rifle that today is
worth about 8,000 to 20,000 somewhere
there estimated and if I hang on to it
another 20 years it'll be worth upwards
of 60,000 so says the the friend helped
me appraise it so how long is this going
to take am I going to be okay and what
do I do about this gun well I would not
keep the gun as an investment I would
keep it as an heirloom and so that's not
it doesn't fix anything today to sell it
it doesn't figure your situation if it
was worth five hundred thousand you know
we'd have to talk about it right but but
it does it's you know it's probably an
eight or a ten thousand dollar gun it
sounds like and you got a problem what
is your degree in it is in social work
so I committed the cardinal sin of going
to a high-dollar university for a low
paying degree and I have been kicking
myself for it since the day I got the
diploma yeah
have you got a masters or an undergrad I
do and I'm awaiting the date that I can
take my licensure exam I'm waiting to
hear back from the Department of Health
yeah well that'll be helpful because
that again you can open up and do some
private casework stuff
get your income up considerably yeah you
know you're not relegated to a $35,000
income but yeah I've been interviewing
this week for another I mean I'm willing
to take on even another full-time
position at this point I just want to
get back on yeah and it is a ratio of
income to debt we call it the shovel
that you've got to dig out with versus
the hole we're in the shovel to hole
ratio and you got a you got a pretty
good-sized hole here in a medium to
small shovel and so you're on the right
track to do things to get your income up
and but here's the thing let's pretend
how would you say 24 24 25 in a couple
minutes so let's pretend that in the
over the next two years you've doubled
your income with extra work side work
private casework finishing getting your
license all that kind of stuff okay
and you kept living like you're living
mm-hmm if you put $35,000 a year on a
hundred thousand in three years you're
done okay so I think you'll be out of
debt by the time you're 30 okay I think
you'll be out of that probably before
then but I think you'll be I think
you're gonna make it and you've just got
to for the first time in this career
decisions of yours start making
decisions based on how much money you
make and you're gonna have to pick some
places where you can make some money and
you can expand your horizons and you can
stretch your you know stretch your
budget up because if you get that income
up it moves the needle really fast on a
hundred thousand bucks here so you can
do it you can do it and we'll be here to
walk with you kiddo